it's great to see you here tonight tom
with regardless greenie of mature dude
course you've worked with joss whedon
before what's it like being part of that
world of readings yeah when you put like
that gosh you know which haces just is
some he's standing right next to me so I
think ever what I say no Joss is he's an
extraordinary man of immense learning
wit and experience and curiosity he's
just is everything I could hope for in a
director really like and he's been
around long enough has a really amazing
understanding of dramas and the
structure of it dramaturgy and comedy
and he's also has an extraordinary and
compassionate understanding of people
and that's all we're in the business of
and the humanity you know he just gets
people and against the way they work and
the way they want and the way they trip
themselves up on the weight of the
things that they want and you know
that's that's really the the the grip in
the oyster that makes the pearl this is
a seminal I wanted you know to be a
really great artist and in fillmore and
creating after be curious about people
and justice is some one of the most
sensitive and why is he crying about
you